I was eighteen years old in Korean age when I first left my country to study English.
When I first got there, I was with my dad so I felt very, kinda safe...
...even though I couldn't speak English. But after one week, my dad left.
I was all alone and I couldn't speak English. I was just very afraid.
There are two reasons why I went to Canada.
The first reason was just to learn English.
The second reason, to be more honest, I wanted to get out of the pressure...
...that I had to get into a good university in Korea.
Like the Su-neung exam, I didn't want to take it.
That was the more honest reason.
I think it was for six months that I had really hard time.
I always had to carry my dictionary with me,...
...so I can search words that I had to speak at that moment.
After 6 months, I started to be able to listen to what the teachers were saying.
I made a lot of friends, a lot of Canadian friends after 6 months.
So, that helped a lot.
They tried to talk to me all the time.
They thought I was interesting.
I was from Korea.
I repeated everything that they said, so they thought maybe I was cute.
They would want to talk to me more.
I was in Canada for three and a half years.